were you encouraged as of your your last
date day in the office that US policy
towards the Ukraine was headed in the
right direction I was not and why was
that well I was concerned about two
things in particular one was again the
removal of our ambassador and again I
will say for the record that the
president has a perfect right to remove
any ambassador at any time for any
reason
but I was very concerned about the
circumstances in which her reputation
had been maligned repeatedly on
television and in all kinds of exchanges
I felt that that was completely
unnecessary if the president wanted to
remove an ambassador which he did quite
frequently there was a number of
ambassadors removed who were not
political but career officials that was
done but without these kinds of
interventions I wondered what that
message was being sent so there was that
and then in the second front it was very
clear at this point that there was let's
just say a different channel in
operation and relations to Ukraine one
that was domestic and political in
nature and that was very different from
the channel or the loop however you
liked it that I and my colleagues were
in where we were focused on bilateral
relations and u.s. foreign policy toward
Ukraine and these two things had
diverged at this point well I think you
might recall in my deposition on October
14th that I said that very unfortunately
I had a bit of a blow-up with ambassador
Sunderland and I had a couple of testy
encounters with him one of those was in
June 18 when I actually said to him who
put you in charge of Ukraine and when
I'll admit I was a bit rude and that's
when he told me the president would shut
me up and this other meeting it was
about 15 20 minutes exactly as he
depicted it was I was actually to be
honest angry with him and you know I
hate to say it but often when women show
anger it's not fully appreciated it's
often you know pushed on to emotional
issues perhaps or deflected on to other
people and what I was angry about was
that he wasn't coordinating with us
now actually realize having listened his
deposition that he was absolutely right
that he wasn't coordinating with us
because we weren't doing the same thing
that he was doing so I was upset with
him that he wasn't fully telling us
about all of the meetings that he was
having and he said to me but I'm
briefing the president I'm treating
chief of staff Mulvaney I'm briefing
secretary Pompeo and I've talked to
ambassador Bolton who else do I have to
deal with and the point is we have a
robust interagency process that deals
with Ukraine it includes mr. Holmes it
includes ambassador Taylor as the charge
a in Ukraine it includes a whole load of
other people but it struck me one
yesterday when you put up on the screen
ambassador Sunderland's emails and who
was on these emails and he said these
the people who need to know that he was
absolutely right because he was being
involved in a domestic political arrant
and we were being involved in national
security foreign policy and those two
things had just diverged so he was
correct and I had not put my finger on
there I thought at the moment but I was
irritated with him and angry with him
that he wasn't fully coordinating and I
did say to him ambassador Sunland Gordon
I think this is all going to blow up and
here we are doctor I just want to drill
down on this a little bit the the
president the United States commander in
chief and his feeling was at the
National Security Council was always
trying to block him what we were trying
to do was block us from straying into
domestic or personal politics and that
was precisely what I was trying to do
but ambassador sumblind is not wrong
that he had been given a different remit
than we had been and it was at that
moment that I started to realize how
those things that diverged and I
realized in fact that I wasn't really
being fair to ambassador Sunderland
because he was carrying out what he
thought he had been instructed to carry
out and we were doing something that we
thought was just as or perhaps even more
important but it wasn't in the same
Channel ambassador some blended said
let's regroup in the ward room for you
no quick huddle on next steps which to
be honest was quite unusual